keep working I would say like keep my
same mentality just work and just keep
getting better you know former Detroit
Lions linebacker Jesse lemonier has died
he was 25 years old
[Music]
keep growing as a human being and you
know I just I just want to make
everybody else around me just the best
person they can the NFL team confirmed
the news on social media writing that
they are shocked and saddened at the
loss the team remembered Jesse as a
model teammate and wonderful young man
gone far too soon Lions defensive
assistant Kelvin Shepard paid tribute to
Jesse with a broken heart emoji writing
doesn't even feel real that I'm typing
this
and cornerback Jerry Jacobs also shared
some words quote Rest in paradise my
brother may God be with your family the
cause and circumstances surrounding his
death are not known at this time
just buying into everything I've been
coached and over time I've become more
confident with my growth and development
as a man and then going to the football
field and if you have ultimate
confidence Jesse spent time with three
different teams during his two seasons
in the NFL after graduating from Liberty
University he first signed with the Los
Angeles Chargers in 2020 after a
one-year stint with LA Jesse moved over
to Detroit where he played seven games
for the Lions the following year he
signed with the Arizona Cardinals but
left before the season began it means
the world to me just him being so close
to me and someone I looked up to just
being like a huge figure in my life he
survived by his brother Corey who played
Four Seasons in the NFL just seeing him
get on the field it was huge because I
know this is a big stage against Oregon
it was something surreal just to watch
him play Jesse would have turned 26 on
Tuesday
foreign
[Music]